the south american country chile is
about to get a new constitution
political independence and left-wing
parties look set to dominate
construction of the
first draft after this weekend's
landmark poll
as the votes were counted it became
clear that the conservative coalition
of president sebastian pinera had not
achieved its aim of winning a third of
the seats a new constitution was a key
demand of protesters
who took to the streets in 2019 in weeks
of demonstrations that left several
dozen people
dead the vote is being called
chile's most important election since
its return to democracy 31 years ago
this is what pinata said about the
results
in these elections people have sent us a
clear
and strong message
to the government and also to the
traditional political forces
that we are not adequately in tune with
the demands and hopes of the citizens
today indigenous people won obtaining
just
participation which is relevant in the
future constitutional convention
today women also won in that for the
first time in history there will be
equal representation
unique in the world in the future
constitutional convention
all right for morning i want to go to my
colleague benjamin alvarez garuba who
happens to be from
chile he joins me now good evening to
you benjamin let me ask you i mean this
is your home country were you surprised
by this result
good evening bran thank you very much
for having me it was a surprise not by
the fact
that the candidates supported by center
right and right um
parties did not got the majority in this
assembly this was some
something that was expected but the fact
that they pulled so low and did not even
achieve the one third that they wanted
to get in this assembly to be part of
this group they will draft
the constitution was quite shocking also
for them and in big parts of the
population
on the outside this looks like chileans
have decided for
a clear break with the past is that what
it is
it is and that's why it's considered to
be the most important vote since the
return of democracy
and not just a break with the past but
also with political parties if we look
how they voted for candidates that are
supported by center-left
um political parties for example they
were in government
after the military dictatorship and they
also did not poll very well so if we
look at independence that achieved
many seats and this is indeed an equal
race so if you have candidates that
don't have the support the financial
support
to do campaigning during this pandemic
and that they made it into this
convention
it says a lot about how chilean people
are really not happy with the way
that the government and not just the
current government of president siva
stan pineda but also
the other governments have dealt with
this problems that they want to change
with this new framework
yeah it sounds like there's a lot of
protest voting going on here and with
these independents being elected
um do we know what these independents
what they stand for
there are several topics that you can
see during the campaign
so there's a lot of in the indigenous
population
also in the in the campaigns of this
independent um
candidate it's important to remember
that this assembly of the 155 members
will have gender parity that's the first
worldwide and will also have 17 seats
reserved for the indigenous population
so with the independence we have a lot
of topics when it comes to
a climate change when it comes to
protecting the environment when it comes
to
changing the constitution from this the
the current
state that has for example the role the
state has it is rather subsidiary when
it comes
to health when it comes to pension when
it comes to education
and those are reforms that have been
demanded on the streets and let's
remember how this protest started in
october of 2019
massive protests demanding these changes
and people in chile know that the
constitution itself of course
will not solve all the problems so it
will set a framework for the next 40
50 years to do several needed reforms in
the country
yeah well let's hope that this is the
beginning of something very good for the
people of
chile that for sure benjamin
alvarez-gruber with the ladies tonight
on this
important election benjamin thank you
you